first of all how are you feeling i mean
you recently tested positive for covid
it's crazy you know like
i did a group message to the girl saying
i have covered out of precaution yeah
and then all of a sudden tmz sent me an
email that um
to explain my covet case so i feel fine
as you can see
uh first day was brutal you know i we
tested before we filmed the reunion you
know production is very careful when it
comes to that stuff and i was negative
and i had no symptoms
but yesterday i felt like
weird and like you know body ache and i
tested positive so i don't know when i
got it
but so far nobody else from the caster
is covered
oh very good well i'm glad you're
feeling a little bit better anyway
that's good
um listen as an original of selling
sunset i am amazed every season how you
are in the middle in the mix of all this
drama between the women while
simultaneously
actually staying out of the drama for
the most part
how do you do that
i try and you know it's very tricky
because production was the drama right
that's what people watch so
sometimes you will see me ask a question
or make a comment but it's not because i
want to
instigate or say things but if i'm not
going to say or ask the question i'm not
even going to be in the show
so if people tweet about me
they still tweet about me that i'm an
instigator but you know it's like we are
doing a reality show what am i supposed
to do
i can't be completely silent because if
you're completely silent people say oh
she's boring so you can't win i try to
stay away because you know i love i love
the girls and
you know there are more important things
in life
and um
look the most of the drama is around
christine
and christine haven't done anything bad
personally to me
so there is no reason for me to attack
her that being said if she does things
that i disagree on i will probably say i
disagree on the action you know
um like i backed up amanza when she kind
of like went off on her and the walkers
open because i agree with amanza i mean
sorry amanza
so
it's hard all to stay away from the time
it really is
somehow i i manage you do manage though
but there was a really intense scene
this season between christine and all of
the women where chelsea pointed out
um
that to gang up on one person was
perceived as she said as bullying do you
feel a sense of responsibility that the
show is perpetuating this type of
behavior between
women
no you know that the issue is i don't
think we are bullying anyone it might
come across like that because of the
editing as well
look christine christina she can be very
nice and sweet but she does things
unfortunately that hurts other people so
if someone confront her um
about something she did
then she she
say it's bullying but you just confront
with some you know it's based on your
actions so
um
nobody's coming to a tackle
in bullying here the city the brokers
open was amanza and her uh talking
privately then somehow we were all
sitting on the couch and then they had
this like heated argument
um
and we was i mean i stayed quiet i
tried to i didn't want to because
personally i agree with amanza um i
stayed quiet and the venus stayed quiet
and vanessa stayed quiet
so we didn't bully him we didn't attack
her actually recorded right after the
scene i'm like are you okay but she
didn't answer and she made you know i
think when you watch it the the feeling
is
the re it feels like that is because one
person says their piece and then another
person agrees and it and top and on top
and on top and then you've got one
person sitting there
quietly and that's why it starts to look
that way um whereas if one person stood
up and said
you know
guys let's do this you go have a
one-on-one it maybe it wouldn't have
looked that way
you saw christine repeatedly have
one-on-ones with i think at least two
people during the season where she said
i just want to be friends and the moment
she said that a person threw back in her
face again something that she had done
and that vulnerable vulnerable
vulnerability story was then snapped
back by christine
doing a witty humor which then hurts
someone so it just seems that there's
never any grace going back and forth
will there ever be a moment where we can
just call it equal
and the women
we want to see women doing powerful
things together and showing thank you
goodness do you think that that will
happen
so look i mean i wish we showed more uh
deals you know closing instead of the
crazy drama the drama says so it's up to
the producers
look christine personally again she
didn't do anything bad to me yeah she
talked about me whatever she said things
it's fine i get a new man i think she's
hilarious but she does things too to
people behind her back and i'm not going
to go into details um
does she really want to be friends with
them i don't know i mean she can be but
then she does something that kind of
like
you know doesn't show like she actually
have the right intentions
um so that's kind of like something that
i don't trust it completely when she
said that to be honest and i know her
and i'm cordial with christine
i don't know if she really
is capable to be hundred percent friend
and not do something
that could jeopardize the friendship do
you think the women are capable of
forgiving and showing that side of women
also
yes i think hatta was totally
located was
totally going to forgive and she
and she had a great intention uh in this
in the season
um unfortunately for hatter you know
christine tweeted something that was not
cool
um so then heather is like okay you send
me these flowers but then you say that
on social media so which one is it
um right so that was good there i think
mary and christian wanted to at some
point make peace but then christian i
think gave up so that's never gonna
happen probably
right uh mary maybe because of history
right what do you think of of the show i
mean uh it feels like it's perpetuating
women just going at it instead of women
being bosses you know living this
luxurious life selling houses being
there for each other it seems this
season it really was all about these
things i got you i got you i got you i
got you and it's showing women in this
light like we're not all like that
i mean look okay i mean i i agree with
you i look at season one and we all had
um
great real estate scenes and we all saw
that we were all successful and sure the
drama was only in the last episode when
christine attacked michelle but it
wasn't the whole thing it was a fun real
estate drama yeah and i wish moving
forward and
it's not my decision
the season six will show more of that
and it's okay to have a little bit of
drama
but
i do want to see more drama around real
estate because i think there is so much
that we can give the audience with that
without what if christine says what did
christine do and
it does get a little bit old that being
said season five was an amazing you know
did really well on netflix yeah i don't
know you and i think the same but i'm
also gonna think we need to give women
more credit like okay
we can disagree and things can get like
this but we can also find forgiveness be
powerful and then project anyway i'm
just saying i just think ah it's just
such a mismatch no it's true i mean i
agree with you like i wish we had more
look real estate it doesn't it's not as
easy as you see on selling sunset it's
i've been doing it for almost 10 years
you have a lot of things going around
transactions
i mean i like the scene with amanda and
davina like amanda was a very difficult
client i like that i like to say that
then i like the scene with christelle
and bretty no dealing with credit how
much credit you're going to give to the
buyer
i like that i like the romance i like
seeing a little bit of the romance in
the relationships like that's sexy and
fun we need to see more of that for
women listen let's talk about the
reunion my goodness how did you feel
going into the reunion were you nervous
you were you excited
uh what are we gonna see
okay i was really excited going to the
reunion to see everyone i knew it's
going to be fun i knew i knew it's going
to be fun but i also had a feeling it's
going to be heated but then christine
didn't show up so it didn't actually got
heated
uh i think it's going to be interesting
you're going to see a lot of the back
story with jason and michelle you know
like how they feel today a few months
later after the breakup
i'm very proud of both of them for being
so open because it's not easy to talk
about your relationship when you're
trying to move on
so i was a lot of emotions there um so
you're going to see that
obviously you're going to see you know
emma answering questions about micah and
empanadas and all these like fun stuff
um
mary obviously addressed a couple of uh
you know
issues with christine and the whole you
know payout to the clients um
and whatnot and then obviously they
asked me about my still birth and i was
very strong talking about it i didn't
cry
you know sometimes i cry sometimes i'm
very okay with that so it depends on the
moment so you're gonna see a good mix of
everything um
i think it's gonna be an amazing show i
really think and i really honestly wish
christine was there to address some of
the issues that came on season five
but i think she was worried she gonna
get
slammed so she did not show up
i mean i have to be honest that that
would probably be what would happen
right and unless unless a woman would
stand up and be like guys this is enough
unless to make it even but would that
really even ever happen you know we had
a very great host uh then for mcqueen uh
straight guy yeah he was an amazing host
and he has like a lot of tough questions
to everybody from the cast okay and i
think he would be more directed question
versus just an attack so i actually wish
he was there because it was just a
questions and said without like you say
this you say that it wasn't anything
like that so i wish
she actually had the chance to speak
and i explained where she came from and
what you know
what's going on
and also christine um
you know
she's the villain of the show so
unfortunately for her it's always going
to be those
scenes that are not as comfortable but
i wish it was there i have to say it is
really uh you're really incredible and i
and i'm also very sorry about the loss
of your son mason
um was it really difficult watching
selling sunset was it challenging for
you to watch
you know i knew i'm gonna watch myself
pregnant and i knew it's gonna be
difficult um
i was fine i wasn't collapsing when i
saw the season i just looked at the
season as a whole but yeah it's just
like i was 32 weeks when we filmed um my
goodbye party which basically was my
baby shower
um production was shifting the
the see this the scene is my goodbyes
party but it was actually my baby shower
so they were obviously kind enough to
not rub it completely on my face
yeah um and it's one of those things you
know we shoot a reality show
and you don't know how things will
happen and what will happen and
we see a lot of us in the cast going
through two things and
and my story was obviously a terrible
trauma story um yeah the loss of the
baby
it's four months and a half in to to
losing mason and time helps a little bit
but i have moments you know i did it
live yesterday um with an i'm very
involved with the
organization for stillbirth because they
got a lot of messages i'm like you know
i gotta at least help other women and i
did it live on igs so then all of a
sudden just broke down i don't know out
of nowhere so it comes and goes yes
yeah as it does with grief right it
comes in and comes in waves for sure
yeah and i never knew anything about
grief you know like obviously i lost
grandparents but it's a little bit
different because this is an unexpected
one
so it is like wave and it comes and goes
and
it's just life